- Your Google Play listing
A vital part of marketing for your application.
Make sure that the data list is the best
Will improve your app's discovery in the Play Store
As well as convert more traffic to install the app.
Here are ten tips for creating a great listing.
Create a unique icon that grabs attention.
Makes the icon created by a high-quality graphics designer
Your app is prominent in Google Play search results.
Do not make it too abstract.
Reflect the purpose of your app or game and what distinguishes it
.
Remember that the simple and simple symbol is often the most influential.
Add screen shots to devices.
Users want to know what your app looks like on their devices.
So many screen shots are included
For each medium on which your app works,
Including tablets, wear and TV.
Within a vertical and horizontal view
For smartphones and tablets.
Add a special drawing.
Summarize your app or game
In a distinctive and attractive way,
Picture highlights your basic application features,
And how to use it
And what users achieve from it.
The great image attracts users to install the app.
Perform experiments on drawings and texts.
The Store Data List Experiences feature lets you
Experience different graphics and texts
To know which ones are best performing.
By experimenting with various high quality application codes,
Some developers noticed a great improvement
In conversion rates for your store listing.
This method allows you to rely on data
Find out the top-converting element for users
So you can attract more installs.
Add a video.
The video helps visitors of your store listing on Play
In deciding to download your app.
The video should be highlighted
Key features of your app or game
Shows how users benefit from the app.
View the app in use.
If your app is complex or unusual,
We recommend you create a tutorial or video tutorial.
Write an attractive description of the application.
Summarize the utility of your app in the brief description
Keep the description lengthy and brief.
Extended descriptions may not be read
Fully.
The first sentence is to be pronounced.
Attention the user to tell him about
Why install your app or game
And make the rest of the description simple:
What your app does and why it's worth it.
Choose words carefully.
The description is clear and precise to your application
It will place it in the most relevant user searches.
A list of keywords will be considered spam.
Be sure to review and understand
Google Play keyword policy
Shown in the Policy Center.
Translate your list.
Add translated store listings
For all languages ​​and translation support application as well.
If you are requesting professional translation
For your app with the Apps translation service,
You can add text to your store listing
And to obtain a translator as well.
Be sure to translate graphics and videos as well.
He showed some pride.
If you have received awards and received great comments,
So tell this.
I list the prizes.
Include some great comments.
The news of how wonderful your application,
Makes people excited about it.
Reply to comments.
Ratings and reviews will improve from your store listing.
As well as responding to comments to potential users
You are a trustworthy software developer,
As well as build loyalty to existing customers.
Follow these ten tips,
You'll get a better listing of Play Store
And more users who click on the installation.
Visit the Google Play Developer Console
And a good listing of your store now.
If you want to get more tips,
On how to improve the performance of your app or game
Improve your business in applications,
Check out other videos in this series
The download guide "Secrets to the success of applications
On Google Play. "